vous dis je considère que ces avances
pour un projet de loi qui touche au delà
de 200 mille personnes ne peut pas être
adopté à tout vas pas à un moment donné
il faut il faut aller de l'avant
le fait de le faire vendredi valent
aussi le cynisme au total je souhaitais
vraiment quel projet de loi suit son
cours normalement et il impose de sa
vision et aucune urgence objective ce
n'est que le bulldozer qu'on nous fasse
des propositions qui vont donner des
résultats mais la politique que les vers
ont toujours fait c'est bâillonner les
oppositions d'un besoin de d'agir voilà
ça vous donne une bonne idée du ton à
l'assemblée nationale l'opposition ne
digère pas le bâillon que le
gouvernement va imposer de demain pour
faire adopter donc la loi 10 sur la
réforme du système de santé
mais philippe couillard soutient que le
gouvernement n'avait pas le choix face
au blocage du parti québécois c'est
notre premier sujet ce soir il y en a
plusieurs autres daniel tâche à michel
bonsoir à vous trois alors cette loi
donc sur l'île ce projet de loi dit ce
sont les structures dans le système de
santé michel est ce que c'était
nécessaire d'imposer un bâillon un
bâillon est ce que c'est pas en général
quand il ya une urgence
ben c'est toujours ce qu'on dit mais
c'est rarement le cas
il ya des vraies urgences par exemple
pour mettre fin à un arrêt de travail
dans
le secteur public alors que par exemple
la santé des citoyens menacé ça c'est
une vraie urgence mais perturbé l'agenda
politique d'un gouvernement et vouloir
empêcher ça ça c'est pas une urgence
on comprend que du point de vue du
gouvernement ça peut en être une
mais c'est un instrument par ailleurs
qui existe et que tous les partis
utilisent la ceux qui s'indignent
aujourd'hui vont faire la même chose
demain
dans ce cas ci je pense qu'il le débat
était allé aussi loin qu'il pouvait
aller de façon productive leur je pense
qu'on arrivait à une impasse ce qui
était mesquin c'est peut-être de le
faire à la veille d'un conseil national
du pq forcer les gens à se coucher à
minuit 1h du matin puis être laval à
québec et à laval de la main c'était ça
manque un peu de fair play mais
assistait pas vendredi s'arrêter la
semaine prochaine et je pense pas qu'ils
aient un gros scandale
bon on verra quels effets concrets cette
réforme aura sur les usagers mais sur le
plan politique daniel est ce que ça peut
avoir un coût politique pour le
gouvernement car si elle échoue et
sûrement sauf que le système de santé du
québec est le huitième moins performant
au canada le canada étant 18e monde vous
imaginez un peu où il se situe ce
système est paralysée depuis plusieurs
années par les chapelles à l'intérieur
du système que ce soit les syndicats que
ce soit les médecins généralistes ou
spécialistes à une infirmière qui a
passé 25 ans dans le système disait
aujourd'hui on peut même pas changé une
poignée de force ont demandé la corniche
des syndicats est un des médecins
bref la réforme est nécessaire est ce
que celle que propose 10 étant barrette
est la bonne je ne sais pas mon
impression quand on paie mais mon
impression c'est que la population qui
s'inquiète énormément de la qualité des
services de santé au québec est prête à
donner au docteur couillard et au
docteur barrette le bénéfice du doute
mais ça donc d'un gouvernement tasha oui
et je pense que les bains l'urgence qui
est ici c'est l'urgence du gouvernement
qui voit l'anniversaire le premier
anniversaire de
mon élection à s'accrocher et on sait
tous que les grandes réformes les
gouvernements veulent les faire pendant
cette première année pour que la
population puisse les digérer avant la
prochaine élection qui serait non
environ trois ans alors pour ce pour
cette raison je pense que je rejoins à
michel le débat a été très long et ne va
pas changer la chose à notre dialogue
productif à ce stade ci alors
gouvernante parce que c'est un prix
politique moindre imposer le bâillon que
de continuer avec le départ bon michel
on sait que la loi dit c'est la première
étape parce qu'évidemment après ça il ya
le projet de loi 20 et on sait à quel
point les médecins sont opposés à ce
projet là alors c'est cette vraie
bataille qui va s'amorcer ses selles
sont les quotas le médecin que veut
imposer des standards exactement et
d'ailleurs si j'étais à la place de
l'opposition je réserverai mon
indignation pour le projet 20 qui lui va
être débattu de façon extrêmement
hargneuse je dirais mais les médecins
partent pas nécessairement gagnant dans
ce débat là même de façon générale ils
ont l'appui de l'opinion publique
l'horizon de faire dos de la preuve ils
vont devoir expliquer comment ça se fait
que plus on augmente le nombre de
médecins moins on a de services va
falloir expliquer pourquoi ils
travaillent moins d'heures en ontario
pourquoi il
ils prennent en charge moins de patients
en ontario il ya peut-être des raisons
que l'on ne connaît pas mais pour nos
mamans la population qui a un cruel
besoin d'un médecin de famille à quoi
deux tiers des québécois qui arrivent
pas s'en trouver un qui cherche pendant
des années c'est ce qu'on se remette à
ce qu'on leur remet évidemment il faudra
voir ça fonctionne mais pour le moment
je pense que c'est les médecins qui ont
le fardeau de la preuve
mais le débat va être très dur daniel
way en ce moment d'accord avec mes chers
non seulement le débat va être dur mais
les médecins accepteront probablement
aucune espèce de forme de changement à
leur régime de travail à 20 sondage il
ya un an ou deux il est peut être
périmés aujourd'hui mais un an nous il
disait dans l'ensemble du canada
c'est au québec où les médecins ont le
plus l'intention de réduire leurs
charges travaillent 60 % d'entre eux
avait l'intention de réduire leur charge
de travail tu dois te le reprocher non
tout le monde ne doit sa qualité de vie
on doit choisir la façon dont il veut
vivre sa vie mais quand vous êtes
médecin et sa tante sont peut-être plus
élevé que pour un autre ouvrier donc ce
débat sera difficile d'autant plus que
le ministre de la santé le docteur
barrette n'agit pas toujours avec des
gants blancs
il a ce qu'on appelle une face à claque
et ça va donner un débat extrêmement
difficile dit aucun doute là dessus mais
justement tâche est ce que gaétan
barrette peut réussir à entamer cette
réforme sont lacunes du médecin mais ça
va être difficile et coûteux pour
reprendre un peu à oka de l'ontario le
gouvernement ici à couper les salaires
ou et les paiements aux médecins de 2.6
5%
ils les médecins ne sont pas contents
justement ils essayent de repousser et
dire on va faire des actions pour
essayer de trouver des emplois ailleurs
recommandé à nos jeunes médecins de ne
pas essentiellement rentrer dans le
système ou rester dans le système ici
c'est la dernière nouvelle là dessus
alors c'est sûr que les médecins c'est
un homme très puissant et c'est aussi un
groupe d'employés particulier et
important pour la société alors ils
savent qu'ils ont un certain poids quand
ça vient à la négociation
en tout cas ici chacun veut établir un
rapport de force en tout cas les
médecins veulent établir un rapport de
force on verra il ya une bataille pour
l'opinion publique qui se joue en ce
moment je voudrais qu'on parle
maintenant de ce débat sur l'intégrisme
qui a été relancé au québec avec la
sphère de l'imam hamza chaoui on a
entendu donc françois legault de la caq
dire qu'il faut essayer d'empêcher les
gens de prêcher ou d'enseigner des
des choses qui pourraient aller à
l'encontre des valeurs québécoises
daniel est ce que c'est réaliste sur le
point de vue d'un point de vue de ligue
1 on l'a vu tout à l'heure on peut
changer une charte des droits mais une
charte des droits et libertés que ce
soit celle du québec ou du canada
ce sont des documents extrêmement
important et ce sont parmi les meilleurs
charte des droits et libertés au monde
donc on joue pas là dedans comme on joue
dans un livre de messe ou un autre
bouquin inoffensif
c'est très important et on le fait pas
parce que bon il ya quelque part un iman
autoproclamé dénoncé par sa propre
communauté qui fait peur à tout le monde
là où à là où je rejoins françois
legault c'est qu' il est temps et gérard
bouchard l'a dit c'est d'après midi les
québécois sont inquiets très inquiet et
il est temps que le premier ministre
passe à l'action et c'est de faire des
déclarations à j'avais envie dire
farfelu saugrenue vous savez de quoi je
parle
tasha une charte la charte provincial
c'est une loi ça peut être amendée ça
peut être changé mais c'est absolument
vrai daniel dit on peut pas simplement
changer ça parce que on a un cas
particulier et changer ça pour limiter
la liberté d'expression est certainement
sa voix contre la charte
une des valeurs québécoises c'est la
liberté d'expression je pense que c'est
une surréaction sous le code ou sous la
charte québécoise ainsi que la charte
canadienne liberté d'expression est
protégé et si on n'aime pas ce que cet
homme dit qu'on le dise publiquement qu
on écrit des éditoriaux ont fait des
manifestations ont fait quoi que ce soit
mais malheureusement il a le droit de
dire ce qui veut dire liberté
d'expression michel quelle est
l'intention de françois legros derrière
tout ça est ce que ceux de récupérer un
des bols de toute la question
identitaire c'est oui je pense que c'est
largement ça monsieur legault
il y à consulter sans doute mais il doit
bien se douter que son projet aurait de
la difficulté à passer le test des
tribunaux mais sur le plan politique
c'est très habile monsieur monsieur
legault veut repositionner son parti sur
le plan identitaire ça fait partie de sa
stratégie et il sera bien content qu'il
a devant lui un gouvernement qui qui qui
fuit ce débat là comme la peste
on l'a vu encore cette semaine n'était
pas très courageux le premier ministre
s'est caché derrière le maire de
montréal après avoir dit la semaine
dernière que l'intégrisme est un choix
personnel
l'oeil applaudi parce que on empêche
l'imam d'avoir ses locaux c'est pas très
courageux et par ailleurs le parti
québécois lui dans sa course ils sont
divisés sur les mesures à proposer alors
monsieur legault c'est le seul qui
actuellement est assez confortable sur
la patinoire à la cc pour lui c'est
certainement une belle occasion bon en
terminant quelque chose d'un peu plus
ludique il ya eu un sondage de la firme
abacus sur la perception du public sont
les qualités personnelles des chefs de
partis art avoir un sondage auprès de
1000 canadiens alors pour eux stephen
harper serait le mieux placé par exemple
pour donner des conseils financiers à
quelqu'un c'est à justin trudeau qu'il
confierait leurs enfants pour une sortie
au cinéma donc pour faire du baby cité
et thomas mulcair serait le plus enclin
à leur prêter 100 $ s'il avait besoin
d'argent
qu'est ce qu'il faut penser de sa tâche
à ludique mais est-ce que c'est
révélateur quand même bah c'est le
médiator ce qui a trait je pense la
perception de la personnalité de ces de
ses chefs là et je pense que c'est
correct écoute c'est ce que le parti
conservateur dit aussi on est les
meilleurs gardiens de l'économie c'est
l'image que projette ses chefs là et je
passe aussi le fait que monsieur trudeau
et si on pense aussi à une personnalité
chaleureuse on voit que dans les
sondages les conservateurs grève alors
dans une situation où la sécurité les
grandes questions comme celles là sont
de l'avant peut-être cette personnalité
de gardiens n'est pas ce que les gens
veulent autant les sondages les
conservateurs grimpe selon un dernier
sondage ekos grimpe même au québec c'est
intéressant daniel
est ce que ça peut être significatif ce
genre de sondages ça vide avec écoute
est ce que j'irai un camping sauvage
avec justin long et horreur du camping
est ce que je laisserai choisir un film
au cinéma
probablement plus que ce niveau n'a pas
écouté est ce que c'est important en
politique les impressions c'est un
important importante les impressions
qu'on a deux politiciens souvent
erronées et joue beaucoup rappelez-vous
jack layton
quand moment donné les québécois ne
savait plus pour qui voter ils ont
trouvé là quelqu'un de souriant et de
rassurant avec il pourrait passer du
temps avoir du fun à des prendre une
bière ça peut jouer dans ce contexte de
rigueur économique de difficultés
économiques de sécurité les gens
voudront peut-être quelqu'un de plus
fermes de plus solide qu'à 25 consentent
québécois qui sont prêts à voter pour
les conservateurs dans le dernier
sondage faisant vingt sièges c'est
évident que c'est bon aussi pas le cas
on va attendre de voir s'il ya une
tendance avant de pavoiser mais il ya
quelque chose de ce côté là michèle
ouimet
je trouve ça un révélateur ce sondage
lecteurs il ya du gras de motivation
acquis qui porte un éclat qui orienta
choix des lecteurs en vote soit selon
son coeur soit selon sa raison il dit
dans ce sondage là tous les énoncés qui
s'adresse à la raison sont favorables à
monsieur rap tous ceux qui s'adressent
aux choeurs sont favorables à monsieur
trudeau alors eux ils ont ils ont leur
fonds de commerce se moquer lui il est
entre les deux il n'ose corps ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre
oui exactement mais si le débat se
polarise et que des les gens se disent
bon mais lequel des pour le coeur et
qu'elle est pour les raisons lui y est
nulle part rapidement à vous trois est
ce que ça peut quand même donné le ton
dans une campagne électorale 10 secondes
daniel ben écoutez il ya des publicités
qui vous ressemble beaucoup à son neveu
dans ce sondage les libéraux vont des
pins justin trudeau comme quelqu'un de
légers avec qui vous pouvez aller au
cinéma ne faut pas lui confier les rênes
du parti
s'ils veulent un peu comme celui qui
peut vraiment à diriger l'économie et
vous sauver de tous les mauvais coups
qui peuvent arriver à la wii savoir
sacha un tout mais c'est un peu ça
essayer de trouver un coeur on a vu ça
quand il a embrassé ses adversaires lors
de l'accident
3 alors on va voir peut-être un peu plus
de chaleur qui vient de vue je pense
michel
oui bien sûr je pense que ça démontre
bien où sont les forces et les
faiblesses de chacun alors dans ce sens
là je pense que pour les gens qui auront
établir des stratégies électorales c'est
c'est évidemment utile et non je vous
crois qu'il veut venir un camping
sauvage avec moi précisé merci d'achat
mais merci beaucoup michel la semaine
prochaine et dimanche à 11 heures aux
coulisses du pouvoir daniel qui vous
recevra le ministre québécois de la
santé et gaétan barrette